hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a supernatural horror film
called Hellraiser spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
[Music]
Roland Voigt is a wealthy businessman
who seems like a typical middle-aged man
to most but hides a dark secret one day
he makes his assistant Serena go to a
secluded place and receive a puzzle box
the naive girl doesn't know how
dangerous the thing is and holds it the
entire day in the evening she attends
void's house party and meets a
prostitute named Joey they talk for a
while before Serena asks him to go to
the part of the house that has double
doors she has been ordered to do so by
her boss but has no idea why Joey enters
the Deep corners of the Mansion until he
finally reaches the room with double
doors and a high ceiling in the middle
is a platform that holds the puzzle Voit
appears out of the dark and asks Joey to
solve the puzzle claiming that he will
be rewarded for it the guy wants to
leave at this point thinking that the
situation is too strange but he is
intimidated into staying it surprises
him that the puzzle is not too difficult
to solve when he fits the final piece a
blade pops out and impales his
a horrified Joey yells in pain unaware
of what comes next he's used to getting
screwed but not like this seconds later
a portal opens from which chains fly out
and hook themselves into Joey's skin he
screams one last time before he is
ripped apart void simply watches the
incident having known what the puzzle is
capable of he looks at the portal
addressing Leviathan The Entity that
rules over hell the scene abruptly
changes to six years later Riley is a
recovering addict who lives with her
brother Matt his boyfriend Colin and
their roommate Nora one afternoon she is
in her room having fun with her
boyfriend Trevor the other people in the
house can hear them in the kitchen which
makes things awkward Trevor leaves right
after making Matt believe he is not good
for Riley and being able to hear his
sister like that is not good for Matt he
talks to his sister and the two get into
an argument about him being controlling
after the fight Riley goes to Trevor's
place and starts smoking we find out
that she has been lying to her brother
about being sober Trevor asks Riley to
come with him to an abandoned house he
delivered a box to the house a few days
ago and knows that it has something
valuable inside Riley agrees and the two
break into the house in the next hour
when they finally get their hands on the
box and open it they find a cube puzzle
inside unaware of the dangers it will
bring Riley takes the puzzle home later
she gets into a fight with her brother
when he finds out she lied about being
sober Matt enraged by her carelessness
asks her to get out of his house in a
fit of rage Riley takes the puzzle packs
her bags and leaves she goes to a
playground and takes Edibles to escape
reality then she starts playing around
with the puzzle accidentally solving it
a blade Springs out but misses her hand
Riley is soon bothered by an eerie
feeling she senses someone watching her
and as if On Cue a silhouette is seen in
the dark the entity's name is Pinhead
and he is a worker from Hell whose job
is to rip out the souls of people who
solve the puzzle however since the
puzzle blade missed Riley's hands he
cannot take her instead he asks for two
more souls in her place and makes her
chest bleed somewhere else Matt wakes up
from a nightmare and feels bad for
yelling at Riley he quickly runs outside
to look for her and finds her passed out
on the playground trying to help her up
he holds the box and accidentally Cuts
himself not realizing that he is now on
pinhead's Hit List he takes Riley to a
nearby bathroom suddenly Blood starts
flowing from the sink hinting at
pinhead's arrival a loud scream wakes
Riley up but when she enters the
bathroom her brother is already gone she
panics and immediately calls 9-1-1 but
since Matt disappeared entirely they do
not have much to work with they simply
bring a frantic Riley back home and ask
her to issue a missing report the next
morning Colin asks Riley where Matt went
but she cannot give him an answer for
fear of sounding insane they get into an
argument because Colin thinks Riley
isn't trying to help the police because
of the fight she had with Matt when the
conversation starts getting overwhelming
she's storms out and goes to Trevor for
Comfort they spend some time together
which makes Riley forget about her
problems momentarily however she is soon
haunted by the visions of xenobites the
creatures from Hell who are slaves to
Pinhead the next morning she asks Trevor
to help her figure out the secret of the
puzzle she is sure that her brother's
disappearance has something to do with
it because Pinhead was holding the
puzzle while torturing her last night
Trevor helps her find the owner of the
abandoned house and it turns out to be
none other than Serena the assistant who
received the puzzle at the beginning of
the film they find her in a health
center dying from a lung disease Serena
tells the couple to forget Matt and
leave the puzzle with her she also tells
them about her billionaire boss Voigt
who is killed because of his obsession
with the puzzle Riley insists Serena
tell her more about the puzzle but she
refuses instead she tries to snatch the
puzzle out of her hands and is cut in
the process Serena accepts her fate and
claims that she did this to herself
later she sees xenobites in a room who
follow her around the health center
eventually leading her to her Doom upon
reaching home Riley looks up voit's name
on the Internet and finds articles about
him being an occult artifact collector
this guy puts Nick Cage to shame she
also sees that he was linked with
several mysterious disappearances before
his own disappearance six years ago
Riley knows that it all relates to the
puzzle and wants to go to void's last
Mansion to investigate Trevor no longer
wants to support her scared of being
taken away like Matt and Serena I'm too
high for this [__] dude hence Riley goes
to the mansion herself she breaks in and
instantly finds the place spooky it has
huge metal gates that look like they
were made for protection from something
dangerous but the answers to Riley's
questions are solved when she reaches
voit's study room it consists of several
pictures of Pinhead and the cenobites
Riley also gets her hands on a diary
that explains that every human taken by
the xenobites is mutilated and skinned
differently she learns that the puzzle
has six different forms and depending on
which form you solve it into you are
tortured by the afterlife entities it
looks as though Voit was after some sick
form of immortality that he was trying
to attain through the puzzle after hours
of reading Riley suddenly hears someone
whisper her name she looks around and
finds Matt in the hallways she runs to
hug him but is horrified after finding
out that his back has been skinned she
retreats in shock and is caught by Colin
Trevor and Nora who have all come to
help her while Nora and Trevor wait
outside Riley explains to Colin what she
has learned in the past hours she claims
that if she gets the puzzle to its Sixth
and final form she will be granted A
Wish by the god of hell she can ask for
love life knowledge power for Furbies to
come back into style or even
Resurrection the last way is how she
plans to get Matt back Colin thinks she
has lost her mind which frustrates Riley
she goes to show him the puzzle only to
find out she has dropped it somewhere in
the Mansion outside Nora is locked in
her room because of the House's old
mechanical setting as Trevor tries to
get her out someone else in the same
room as her is solving the puzzle the
person uses it to stab Nora and chases
her out of the room a terrified Nora
stays on the ground unaware that since
the puzzle hurt her her Doom is near
Colin and Trevor pick her up and run
outside while Riley picks up the puzzle
and follows after they leave we find out
the man in the walls is Voit himself the
trio takes Nora outside the Mansion to
their van while trying to drive away
from the Mansion a sudden Force makes
them lose their way whilst driving in
panic the puzzle starts moving which
throws them into Terror unknown to the
fact that the xenobites have started
their execution the trio drives in fear
not knowing what the right path is Nora
on the other hand finds herself being
taken by the xenobites where she
ultimately meets her death through
Pinhead Riley sees pinhead's reflection
in the mirror and grasps the situation
consequently their van crashes and they
come out to find Nora is nowhere to be
seen while all on their way back Riley
meets Pinhead who offers Matt's
Resurrection for two more sacrifices
which she refuses momentarily caught in
the conversation Riley gets stabbed and
is now marked Pinhead then tells her
it's either her own life or two others
somehow the group finds their way back
to the mansion when a xenobite follows
them failing to catch up with the other
two Colin falls down with the fear of
what is before him however the xenobite
leaves him for the now marked Riley in
the process the xenobite injures Trevor
but Riley refusing to give up any of the
other two his sacrifice solves the
puzzle and stabs the xenobite who then
meets his death finally the three make
it back to the mansion however their
safety is still not insured with many
cenobites making their way towards them
just then Riley locks the metal doors
upon realizing the framework designs
surrounding the whole mansion keeps the
xenobites out leaving an injured Trevor
to rest Colin and Riley set off alone to
find some solution now the alone and
resting Trevor gets a visitor who is
revealed to be void it is further
disclosed that Trevor was voice Lackey
and has been working to find people to
sacrifice to the Box including Riley the
medals crackling reveals a Contraption
attached to void that twists and leaves
him in pain he then presses on Trevor's
wounds and tells him to speed up the
process and offers sacrifices to get his
reward as he is no more patience left in
order to trap a cenobite Riley and Colin
move Trevor to control the switch then
Riley offers herself to Pinhead but is
actually using herself as bait to lure
in and trap a xenobite they become
successful in trapping one but
unfortunately Riley drops the artifact
during the process while everyone is on
different sides of the metal cage Colin
goes to find it but fails as void is
faster in doing so and stabs Colin
instantly shocked at the existence of
void Riley informs Trevor but he is
unvexed by it unvexed nice our writer
has dope words today Riley then learns
about everything that Trevor did for
Voigt and how he was with her in hopes
of sacrificing her she also learns that
Voit was able to get the sixth solved
puzzle six years ago and was granted A
Wish by the god of hell he wanted a new
pleasure Sensation that got him the
contraption attached to his body this is
when she finds out that the truth behind
any reward offered by the cenobites is
pain Sato masochist gang rise up as the
puzzle reconfigures itself like every
other time the portal opens for yet
another sacrifice and on void's command
Trevor opens the gates letting the Cena
bites in Riley pleads with Colin to run
which he does but is followed by
xenobites taking the opportunity Voigt
locks all the gates trapping the
cenobites demanding Leviathan to set him
free from the gift just as Leviathan
appears in the sky Voit fails to keep a
check on Riley who then takes the Box
unlocks the door and goes to find Colin
with the tables turned now gets on his
knees and asks Pinhead to just let him
die so he doesn't have to suffer anymore
trapped and almost ready to be mutilated
Colin screams in pain Riley reaches the
scene and offers the Cena bite another
sacrifice in place of Colin Riley goes
to Trevor who is initially sent by void
to not let Colin escape and stabs him
the cenobite instantly releases Khan and
captures Trevor who is mutilated right
then and there Riley is successful in
Saving Colin from the torture meanwhile
void is asking Pinhead for anything but
the gift being true to her grounds she
informs him that no gift could be
ungiven however she tells him that
exchange was possible and furthermore
admits that they were wrong about him
that he never sought sensation and that
everything he did for pleasure was for
power Voit immediately chooses to
exchange his gift for power Pinhead then
steps back and lets Leviathan give him
his final salvation unquestionably the
metal Contraption comes off his body and
his wounds heal it does not last long
however as a long chain comes crashing
through the ceiling and pierces through
him and lifts him away decidedly
everything calms down and Riley goes to
the cenobites who offer her a reward for
completing all the sacrifices her
brother Matt calls to her as they offer
to resurrect him but she chooses not to
as she has already learned from void how
everything is Twisted this must be how
the Halo TV show came to light she tells
them that she accepts his death the
cenobites notify her that she has chosen
lamentation as a gift by choosing to
live with the guilt for all the
sacrifices she made she leaves the
artifact on the floor which reconfigures
itself with The Disappearance of the
cenobites Riley and Colin returned to
the van where Colin asks her if she made
the right decision but Riley stays naked
I mean silent [__] I read ahead there
Riley stays silent in the last scene
Voigt wakes up naked hairless and
trapped he then gets brutally
transformed into a scene receiving the
gift of power that he truly desired
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching